Our next story shows that a mother's love
truly knows no bounds.
Myles Harris is a reporter
at our affiliate station, ABC 6 in Columbus, Ohio.
And he was covering a story
when his mom Sandy drove by
and couldn't resist saying hello.
The clip went so viral.
(Ross laughs)
More than eight million views!
Watch this, if you haven't seen it already!
Is it 'cause of the... ?
It's my mom, hold on.
Hi, baby!
(camera man laughs)
I'm trying to work right now,
and you're here calling my phone.
This is D'Angelo, you can say hi.
Hi, D'Angelo!
And don't be holding up traffic,
'cause you got cars behind you.
All right.
Did you record that?
(audience applauds)
He's right here at the news desk,
a fellow newsie, Myles Harris is here!
(audience applauds)
Hello!
What is going on, y'all?
This is awesome!
I'm so excited to be here.
Oh my gosh, I'm so thrilled that you would come here
and do the show.
We all were passing this clip around
our own little news team.
Uh-huh, it was everywhere.
Everyone I know is talking about this clip.
What did that feel when it went viral?
What did that feel like?
Honestly, it's just so crazy to think about it.
You never know, like, a video like this
is gonna go viral.
Especially like just, me and my mom just being ourselves.
We're really just being ourselves.
All of our internal family and friends are just like,
"This is so much like you guys' relationship."
And to know that, not just our friends and family,
but now the world knows how cool of a mom she is.
Do you think your mom can contain it?
No, I can't control Sandy.
There's no chance of that happening.
(audience laughs)
I can't control Sandy.
Sandy is her own person,
and we're in our own relationship.
But like, no.
It was kind of, I wouldn't say the word embarrassing,
but just you know, my mom's just super happy to see me.
Like, kind of going from where we've been
and kind of moving our way up
and just doing all that.
And just, she wants a front row seat.
My mom's my number one cheerleader.
(audience applauds)
So any time she gets to see me, you know,
she loves it.
And you know, gosh,
I wish every mom could be here right now.
You know, I wish your mom could do a drive by
right this very second.
(Myles laughs)
Yeah.
And give one of her cute hellos.
When they did that...
We did that on Saturday one day,
and then on Sunday, the anchors caught wind of it,
and they were like, "You have to post this on social media."
And then all during our newscast,
they were trying to tease, like,
"Hey, I wonder if Sandy's gonna show up."
Oh!
(audience laughs)
They were like, telling us what street we were on,
doing all that stuff,
and they were all playing along with it, so.
Well, your mom couldn't get off work
to be here with us.
But will you look at the camera
and just send her a message
and say hi to her?
Yeah, well, first of all,
obviously, I love you.
This wouldn't be done without you.
This whole situation, being able to show the world
just how amazing you truly are.
Hi, baby!
(Myles gasps)
(audience laughs and applauds)
Don't cry.
Get it all nice and cozy for you.
Thank you.
And clean it off.
Sandy, I'm...
I'm so thrilled to see you!
Oh!
Sandy, I feel like we are actually
getting the moment that all of us wanted,
which was you out of that car
and into our dreams.
Oh!
(audience applauds)
As the Billy Ocean song goes.
Don't cry, don't cry.
Oh, no, do cry, I love it!
Oh, it's so meaningful.
Oh, he's gonna make me cry now, stop!
(audience laughs)
May I ask what's going through your head
and heart?
We've just been through a lot.
You know, my mom's a single parent,
and so,
for us to get to this position.
It's not easy.
She's worked three jobs.
(indistinct)
Went to the best schools.
So like, doing even things like graduation,
it's not just me walking across that stage,
she's there with me.
Being on the stage, it just,
whether she showed up or not,
she's always with me.
And to be able to do this
in front of everybody, just
it means so much.
(audience applauds)
Aww.
He means set the bar...
Oh, my baby!
I think he means set the bar for love.
(upbeat music)